what are the holidays gonna look like in
your household by the way
oh gosh well i mean me and my family
kind of always have a low-key holiday i
just spend it with my
parents and my two brothers and they've
been
at the house so i see them all the time
so it's not really
anything out of our ordinary so that'll
be nice
um but it's going to be low-key and i'm
glad that i can
see my family and yeah
because a lot of people can't this year
so yeah is there like a
a holiday meal that you actually are
like looking
forward to more than anything else it's
like thanksgiving part two right
i mean like that's what we do we make
like pretty much the same thing we make
on thanksgiving for a christmas dinner
like we make a turkey
and all the pies and the desserts and
i i'm in the kitchen hooking it up all
day long
so i'm looking forward to you know i
just kind of
finished off my thanksgiving leftovers
so yeah
i'm looking forward to a fresh batch of
leftovers
every time you think you're out they
pull you back in
right back in for those mashed potatoes
so i know that you've been really busy
at home with i mean with everything that
you've been working on
including comfort and joy when did you
actually record this
so i started off quarantine in the year
working on
a new album because i was you know i
at first i wanted to go on tour this
year so that was the first
big blow is that i had to figure out
what i was going to do with all this
free time so i pretty much
dove right back into recording a new
album and just being in the studio every
day because i have a studio at my house
and
when i kind of get in a mode i get like
really in a mode so
i found myself just recording a ton of
songs like a ton
and uh it felt like i needed to
kind of take a break from that project
and pace myself creatively
so i definitely shifted gears and
started focusing
on creating the holiday album probably
around
august august august yeah yeah
august how do you how do you get
yourself in like
the holiday spirit during like during
august september yeah
um you don't
i was not in the holiday spirit but i
just love a good holiday vibe i was just
thinking about all of the
just you know how happy energy
that christmas songs bring to people and
all of the just
positive moods that the songs exude so i
wanted to
to bring that i think around the time i
was i went to dc
for a black lives matter protest and
that was where i really was like okay
this christmas project is like this is
really gonna happen
like let's walk in let's make sure that
we bring people some joy this holiday
season
right it felt like an important thing to
do yeah absolutely i just feel like this
year has been really heavy for all of us
and we've all been through so much
um with corona virus and and everything
that we've been through so
um it made sense for me to just put out
something that felt light-hearted
and i didn't have to have a ton of
pressure on it it's just a good music
and good vibes
and a gift for my fans so we can all
just
have some good vibes this holiday season
yeah
what is the vibe on this like is this is
this like a traditional holiday vibe
because your cover of last christmas i
was reading the comments
and someone goes like only tenacio could
make
uh last christmas sexy right like
yeah okay thanks um for me i just wanted
to make them all my own
and to really kind of give them a fresh
spin because i love the
holiday classic songs so i didn't want
to do like a bunch of original songs i
want to
when i hear holiday songs i want to hear
the christmas songs
in a new way or in a fresh way so i kind
of just tried to reimagine them and take
a fresh approach
like god rest you marry gentlemen i like
trapped it out and like put like a whole
808 on it
and like you know just stuff that makes
you want to dance and i feel like
i haven't really heard some of the songs
presented
in this particular format before so yeah
i just made it my own
just give it a fresh spin
look how how awesome is it going to be
when you hear people bump and digress
you marry gentlemen
out of their trucks right i want to see
i want to see some tick tock dancers i'm
waiting for someone to make the tick
tock dance for it you know
100 percent do you do you remember
like the very first christmas song that
you knew
all the words too as a kid like like oh
i know this one top to bottom they're
gonna make me [ __ ]
every christmas i knew like every song
all the words like
that's like what i love to do i love
songs so there's
i i memorize songs really easily and
really quickly like every year we play
this game with my family like who can
name the most christmas songs
or who can rattle off the most before
you run out i always win
every year so i can't i can't name like
a one
song because i'm sure i
i love them all there's so many good
ones
did you have to do that thing growing up
where like people would say okay you
gotta you gotta
do a performance for us now it's the
holidays you got to do a performance for
us now
nobody had to twist my arm to do a
performance it was more like oh i'm
giving a performance
everybody get ready and we would i would
make a program
and list all the songs i was performing
i had choreography i would teach it to
my brothers
and then we would do it every year so we
had like consistency with our
performances
yeah major major events in my house
i love that it's cool that you have your
your family with you
um if i was gonna bring them on this
room right now and say like okay
is she on the naughty list or the nice
list what do you think they would say
like what would they say about you i'm
so nice
like please i've yeah i mean
this year's been pretty low-key i don't
think i could have done too
too much bad stuff i've been pretty
locked down corona free
trying to be safe you know just focused
on music
and getting a lot of sleep so i don't
think i've
i think i've been pretty nice this year
good
now i'm all about the holiday movies i
think um your favorite holiday movie
says a lot about you
mine is scrooged i love that that's my
number one
is a curveball yeah it's a curveball
what's your number one best holiday
movie of all time
um i kind of like the muppets christmas
carol
like specifically the muppets version
like i really like
it's a good one it's a good one the
mother's version of anything is actually
the best version of it yeah it's so good
yeah i mean i mean i like like your your
basic like i like elf
you know who doesn't like elf um i like
uh
i like even some of the classics like um
uh what is it what's the one that's all
in black and white and the angel comes
down he's like
oh i'm gonna say you know you know what
oh uh
uh it's a wonderful life yeah
wow that one's a good one that's a
classic and then uh
i mean i have beef with the polar
express everybody likes that movie but i
think it's overrated but the only reason
why i feel like i could say this
is because i was in it so i feel like i
have room to criticize
for what is it i it kind of it kind of
creeps me out the animation creeps me
out when i watch it
and now i'm like yeah it was very early
on
in that kind of era of using the
electrodes and then animating over the
top of
it so yeah it's it's it's interesting to
see how
much improvement they've made in those
areas as well since then
but i mean even though you're 15 years
ago
it's funny that you're like i'm critical
of my of my earlier work
you're in a classic like that's amazing
yeah it's really dope it's super dope
that every year
i can find it i get that little residual
check that's always cute
yeah i just think it's funny a lot of
people really love that movie i'm always
like
uh finally finally um is there anything
specific on your like wish list like
what do you
what are you looking for this year what
are you wanting this year um
what do i want this year uh
i kind of wanted to this is super random
i kind of wanted like a
like a digital animator like something
that i could draw
or paint or do my art digitally because
i
make a lot of art in my free time just
for fun
um but then it kind of ends there
because i can't like really share it as
well because like for example like these
like i make art but
yeah take a picture of it so i don't
know i think it'd be kind of cool to
delve into some digital art nice
okay so procreate
photoshop i literally asked it to santa
to figure out
what that what to do i just i just gave
you your answers i just gave your answer
right there that's good
thank you all right this has been so
nice
uh good talking to you uh happy holidays
absolutely stay safe
you